erst mal an der box natürlich recht alle
gucken was heißt das für mich bis runter
zu den einzelnen abgeordneten ich glaube
dass es eine chance gibt das zu machen
weil ja die parteien insgesamt noch viel
mehr angst davor haben müssen dass die
bürger sich so noch weiter von ihnen
entfernt also der druck in der
bevölkerung ist sehr groß ich bin nicht
dafür müsste nicht falsch zu verstehen
dass der bundesrat so groß ist
ich wollte nur darauf hinweisen dass
natürlich viele menschen als sie gesehen
haben dass dann nur noch elf gesetzt
wahrscheinlich gedacht warum nicht auch
so
der mann wird ein mittelweg finden
müssen weil die wahlkreise auch nicht zu
groß werden dürfen
mein früherer wahlkreis das war also 300
330.000 bürgerinnen und bürger als sich
landtagsabgeordneter war hatte ich ein
bruchteil davon und konnte jedes dorf
besuchen als bundestagsabgeordneter ist
das schon viel schwieriger wir müssen
aufpassen auf der einen seite sagen wir
die abgeordneten sollen sieger war vor
ort blicken lassen
auf der anderen seite machen wir die
wahlkreise dann sehr sehr groß diesen
mittelweg zu finden wer sich ganz
einfach aber ich glaube dass das möglich
ist übrigens sinnvoll ist immer eine
wahlrechtsreform für die übernächste
wahl zu machen damit bei der nächsten
wahl keine angst haben muss er sei davon
betroffen oder vom aktuellen trend
betroffen wir haben damals in
niedersachsen solche wahlrechtsreformen
dann immer für die übernächste wahl
gemacht und es war dann einfacher
mehrheit dafür zu finden und kompromisse
zu schließen
herr gabriel keiner ist zufrieden mit
den vorschlägen der anderen aber schuld
an der blockade sind trotzdem immer die
anderen ihre kollegen der spd
parlamentsgeschäftsführer carsten
schneider macht die union natürlich
verantwortlich dass die reformen seit
jahren verschleppt wird die union sei
hier zitat nicht aus dem quark gekommen
hat er recht ich glaube dass sie sich
alle gegenseitig beschuldigen und jeder
aus seiner sicht heute hätte recht die
wahrheit ist beide haben sich
hingekriegt
es geht nicht ums rechthaben sondern
beide haben sich weder die spd noch cdu
csu haben ihre interessen ein stück
aufgeben wollen das müssen sie aber tun
die werden weil mit
da kompromisse finden müssen sonst geht
es nicht immer nur auf den anderen zu
zeigen ist das alte sprichwort wenn die
mit einem finger auf den anderen zeigen
zeigen drei mindestens drei auf mich
zurück und so geht's cdu/csu wenn die
spd bestimmt sind und so geht es der spd
wenn die cdu/csu bestimmt
[Musik]